from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between pocky in japan and leguis this
is food wars
[Music]
in japan our pocket comes in a 72 gram
box which contains two pockets
and a nine pack
our pockets come in basically three
sizes the 1.14 ounce box the 2.47 ounce
box and the 4.13
ounce
boxy bag but our strawberry flavored box
is smaller than this chocolate box this
is a 3.81 ounce box which is .32 ounces
smaller than this one largest box bag is
this the cookies and cream flavor which
is
4.57 ounces or .44 grams larger than the
chocolate box one theory my theory is
that the pocky boxes contain a specific
number of pocky sticks and each pocky is
a different weight based on the flavor
coating so we're gonna weigh each pocky
individually to see if this is true
all right chocolate first
so seven of these
are 13 grams can someone write that down
strawberry seven is
13 grams
was that what the first one was okay
cookies and cream cookies and cream
seven of them
are 18 grams well the cookies and cream
ones are definitely a lot heavier a lot
heavier
so let's see how many pocky are in a box
[Music]
32 33 34
34 pocky in total so one pocket has 17
pocky and another one also has 70 pocky
let's see how many pockets are in this
box
oh man
is this normal
i think i could cut him like do you want
to get like a close-up on on there
before so one two three those are broken
ones
30 31 32 33 34 35 36.
you know how everyone was complaining
about how i eat kitkats in the kitkat
episode
here's all the pockies that are native
to the us that are not in japan and here
are all the pakis native to japan
cookies and cream
cookies and cream not a solid block so
that's good
yeah
yeah
yeah
i like those this looks like fun yuli
chocolate banana have you had these
before you have
yeah mm-hmm
that banana flavor hits like right away
oh no
much of green tea any food wars heads
watching now
joe does not like matcha
smells like a freshly cut lawn
yeah yeah
there's also a crunchy strawberry flavor
you can get here in the u.s but i was
not able to get my hands on it by the
time of filming this episode so
here's this regular strawberry
oh
oh another
solid block
mmm well good
put me in jail for crimes against
monkeys
george's energy
let's go
all right let's start with this one we
have pocky luxury milk chocolate
is it pocky
you look like corn dog
what happened to you
it's got milk
and fermented butter flavor
and we have another corn dog it's an
almond milk flavor
oh shadow
mmm
it has strong almond milk flavor
i prefer this one
the milk chocolate but both are so short
you should be longer
you do
we have
this ultra theme pocky
oh
you're so thin
this time
this one is short
this part is so thin
we have
tasty why is it tasty oh
fermented butter is used for this stick
it's got just a little bit of
butter flavor
i still prefer this one
this corn look
i'm on the crush
it's a little bit different look at the
pockets
yeah obviously it's got almonds
i love this
i love this
um we've got hockey chocolate coconut
oh this one is also
this style of pockets
it's pretty similar with this one almond
crush
yeah obviously it's got coconut flavor
and also it's got a little bit of
saltiness it's not my taste
strawberry chocolate pocky
right after you bite this you get some
sweetness but after that you get
sourness it smells so strong
i can smell it from here
cocoa powder pocky
and it says you can only get this in
winter season oh yeah look at this it's
got cocoa powder
we've got the cutest pocky ever
cherry heart-shaped hockey
look at this
heart is in there
how cute
and this part cherry chocolate is so
awesome
you get strong cherry flavor
we've also got blueberry heart-shaped
chocolate pocky
look at this
so blue
this color doesn't make me want to eat
this
but let's try
it
[Music]
so sour
but look at this heart-shaped pocky
not for me
this is what i've been waiting for
sakura matcha
so sakura means cherry blossom
cherry blossom matcha taste
ooh
look at this
so it's got matcha chocolate
and this stick is
pink
this is so japanese pocky just sweet
matcha the feeling of spring has come to
my life
spring is here in my body
[Music]
and everybody is curious what these are
what does it mean i don't even know
anyway so it says mega mino ruby it
means like goddess
ruby
in english it says amber kind of like
stone fossil jewel
it says it goes well with
red wine interesting
it looks like regular chocolate pocky
oh
what is this
this test itself is like berries this
one goes well with whiskey
it's pretty close to dark chocolate it's
bitter in japan we have this kokubo so
extra fine pocky which are roughly half
the thickness of a regular chocolate
pocky and in the u.s ours are called the
ultraslum
i got a new digital scale what i'm gonna
do is weigh a regular chocolate pocky
2.13 grams
so ultra thin hockey so it weighs
1.52 grams
thinner
that's it
here's the big boy
here's the thing
is is it able to do this okay like get
out of the way so it's just the white
background 23 24 25 and there's another
bag in here so 50 per box
okay so 50 instead of 36 seven regular
pockies are 13 grams let's see how many
slim ones we need to get to 13 grams
five six seven
eight and a half eight and a half slim
ones are the same as seven regular ones
is that that much slimmer i guess that's
slimmer does anyone think that that's
like not significant enough to be a
selling point
pocky adjusts its sweetness for
different countries not surprisingly the
us ones are meant to be sweeter i'm
going to do a taste test side by side
we've got the american ones hear the
japanese one and we're going to see just
how different they taste i'm worried
that these are also going to be a
a pocky popsicle oh no
okay japanese these are only japanese
ones i could find obviously they're
bigger i don't know if this is the norm
in the baseline sweeteners
yeah it's noticeably different
they taste identical
but ours has
like a sweet aftertaste
i like i like japanese ones much better
sapaki is in the guinness world records
three times it's the largest chocolate
coated biscuits brand has the most
mentions of a brand name on twitter in
24 hours which was three million seven
hundred ten thousand forty four times
and finally was part of the most people
opening packaged food online
simultaneously with 143 people 143
people that's it that doesn't seem like
that many i feel like i've been on zoom
work calls with 143 people in it right
it would have been literally one email
to set that up i can do
kakibu
[Laughter]
now
i got more than 200 versus clowns right
here
simultaneously three two one
now i broke the guinness world records
so november 11th is known as zapaki nohi
or pokeday in japan
this date was chosen because a [ __ ] is
shaped like a 1 and november 11th
visually looks like for pocky
and also pets are included in this day
november 11th which is the pretzel
version of [ __ ] and in japan you can get
them in flavors like salad ripe tomato
sweet potato and
roasted bread flavor
in the u.s we also have pretz and we get
these fun flavors like
sweet corn
fun
and
pizza oh
god nothing on it
nope
i mean
yeah it tastes like
corn
why though what is the demand for corn
flavored
sticks
besides pizza anything flavored like
pizza is terrible even pizza combos
aren't very good
no
i mean it's up there with like croutons
does anyone grab a hand full of croutons
on the go and we're just eating a box of
croutons like these probably would be
good on something
in japan our chocolate pocky box for 100
grams has 506 calories adjusted for the
box size 72 grams the package contains
364.3 calories
and let's break it down even further to
per pocky pumpkin contains on average
11.38 calories
a u.s chocolate pocky box contains 340
calories just a little bit less than a
japanese box but note there is a two
gram difference now here at food wars we
thrive on scientific accuracy so let's
break it down per pocket one u.s pocky
is 9.444444
four four four four four four four four
four four four four four four calories
the highest calorie pump in japan is to
be determined we emailed the customer
service but we didn't get their response
what are doing hurry up
but i guess the spocky
is the most calorific pocky it's
196 calories
so should be
because it's got a lot of butter in it
the u.s pocky with the most calories is
the cookies and cream it contains total
630 calories there's no question i could
murder this whole box in one setting 630
calories that's nothing that's that's
like kind of reassuring like wow only
630 found my breakfast
[Music]
pokey contains these ingredients wheat
flour sugar cacao mess vegetable oils
whole milk powder shortening malt
extract starch salt yeast cocoa powder
butter emulsifier flavoring leavening
agent anato coloring and mineral salt
any us pocket contains wheat flour sugar
chocolate liqueur blend of vegetable
oils that blend being sunflower oil palm
oil whole milk powder vegetable oil
shortening which is palm oil
hydrogenated palm oil cocoa butter salt
artificial flavors yeast soy lecithin
leavings sodium bicarbonate mono and
diglycerides of fatty acids wink
in japan our pocky contains milk extract
which is sometimes used as a replacement
for sugar in baking it contains lots of
maltose a type of sugar which actually
has a higher glycemic index value than
normal sucrose so it's a surprise that
american pocky are supposed to be
sweeter
there are actually differences in the
types of cocoa used if you've watched
the us vs uk snickers episode you know
that american chocolate
isn't that so great in the u.s our
pockets are made with chocolate liqueur
and cocoa butter chocolate liqueur is
just cocoa that's been processed into
semi-solid form and it's actually around
50
cocoa butter itself the trouble is for
an american product to be classified as
milk chocolate only needs to contain
around 10 percent of chocolate liqueur
and the rest can be made up of sugars
and various ingredients
in japan the rules are different
depending on the type of product milk
chocolate material must contain at least
21 cocoa content double the required
amount in america so our chocolate has
more chocolate are you jealous of us
come to japan
so if i had dude go
favorite flavors i'm gonna go
number one number two
these two pocky
these are the best ones grab your glocky
when you see tupacki